Uh,
hi Jordan.
and what x number of a producer with the
agenda,
Steve in the TVO and you are Jordan
Peterson,
professor of psychology at the
University of Toronto.
And this is our third conversation about
various subjects.
And this one we decided there's going to
be,
uh,
about,
about the future,
the idea of it and then perhaps even the
actuality,
uh,
the reason why,
why,
uh,
the future is the subjects because you
and I have talked much about it and let
me start with my own,
uh,
brief take on it.
Um,
my sense is that we are running out of
future with capital apps.
Uh,
for about 10 years.
we had,
uh,
the um,
the I and access to,
to the idea of future as an ever
growing,
ever improving a prospect for humanity
and a,
and we are at the point where we no
longer have easy access to that belief.
Um,
do you agree?
And if so,
what do you think is responsible for it?
Well,
it seems to me like it's a continuation
of the process that needs to talk about
in the late 18 hundreds when he
described the death of God.
Yeah.
I mean he,
by the death of God,
he man really the collapse of
Christianity or maybe of Judeo
Christianity and the loss of the meeting
structure that went along with that at
the same time as he proclaimed that
itchy also hypothesized or prophecy
really that,
that,
that belief system would be replaced by
is that vast political belief systems.
He thought co I've communism
particularly and,
and he knew that even at that early time
that many millions of people would die
during the transition and meaning
systems and now that we're out of the
20th century,
those of collapse too mean very few
people hold any brief with Utopian
political views,
whether they're on the right or the
left.
So we've also lost that.
Then the question is,
what's left after that and announced
that seems to be,
it's anybody's guess.
I think we're also swamped by
technological change that's occurring at
such a rate that it's become impossible
to predict the direction of the future.
So,
but obviously when,
when we talk about the future,
we imagined a moral enhancement,
uh,
of,
of the human condition.
Uh,
we imagined that a progress man,
not only technological progress,
not only economic progress,
but moral progress.
Um,
and,
uh,
and the question is whether or not this
was adler a,
a viable
prospect.
I wasn't just a watered down
Christianity,
uh,
for the benefit of those,
who've lost faith niches.
Primary point with the death of God was
that you can't have moral improvement
without a moral system because you know,
people think there are things that are
self evidently moral,
but you know,
it turns out that they're part of a much
broader fabric.
So yes,
I would say to some degree it was,
it was,
uh,
the remnants of water down Christianity
playing itself out.
And the question,
I suppose to some degree is what's after
that?
And you know,
the,
the atheists,
especially the radical atheists would
have us believe that,
you know,
we could move towards a kind of rational
sense of the world along with whatever
rational ethic would go along with that.
But I don't really believe that.
I don't think there's much reason to
believe that people will become more
rational as the future progresses.
I mean,
I think they might become more diverse.
Lee Irrational.
That's kind of how it looks to me.
What do you mean by that?
That nervously rational,
he diversely irrational,
splintered into their own little
subgroups of meaning,
I suppose.
I mean,
why would we assume that people would
become more homogenous?
Homogenous when in their,
in their private,
in their private beliefs.
I mean,
the rise of all these strange new age
religions,
which you know,
we'll have collected any number of Dave
ots seems to indicate that there's
plenty of room on the irrational side
and mean Islamic fundamentalism
certainly hasn't managed Jenny
disappearance.
Maybe you could think of that as the
last great hangover of the,
of the Abrahamic religions.
You know,
that,
that'll,
that's under attack and will disappear
too.
But I don't see that people are
progressing towards the kind of
rationality that the atheists would like
to presume as are our natural
destination.
Just I just don't think people are that
rational or capable of that degree of
rationality.
Why?
What's the argument for that?
Well,
I think it's the incompleteness of
rationality.
Personally,
I don't think,
I don't think rationality can survive on
its own.
I think it's,
it's like the capitalist system.
It has to be embedded within a
functioning government.
No matter what the capitalists claim,
the market isn't the bottom governmental
agreements,
the bottom,
the ultimate container and rationality
has to survive within a mythology and
the rational is don't believe that.
But I think that that's just because
they're still protected by the
mythology.
They can get away with that clint
rationality.
Once you,
once you agree on the presuppositions,
then rationality can guide you to a
destination.
But I don't see how rationality can help
you establish the presuppositions at
all.
What's more important?
Curing cancer or stopping stopping the
whale hunt?
Let's,
let's look at it that way.
What's more important?
Putting money into education or for
sure,
or healthcare.
There's these terrible moral decisions
about
which normally,
normally we don't need to decide either
or.
I mean,
normally in the course of human affairs
we decide that,
uh,
we will throw certain amount,
for this,
uh,
goal and another amount for another
goal.
And,
and so,
and the,
and the amounts might shift,
might shift.
It's never a question or so.
So,
so the question of I think,
I think I would,
people who are watching this might
really want to understand what it is
that you mean by presuppositions.
Uh,
that said that that needs to be
embedded.
Uh,
before we can talk about the reason
a functioning belief system helps you
figure out what things are more
important than what other things.
And you know,
those are,
I suppose the 10 commandments would be
an example of that.
Are there things that are supposed to be
established without question and you
know,
you might think some of them are
obvious.
People say that about the 10
commandments,
thou shalt not kill.
That's obvious.
It's like,
well,
it turns out that that's not so obvious
at all.
It's obvious because it's,
it's such an inherent part of our,
the fabric of our society.
And we assume that it's wrong,
but there's been lots of societies that
have been organized around the
principles of the warriors societies,
for example.
And we're already,
we're already discussing exceptions to
the rule.
Thou shalt not kill.
I mean,
that didn't that happen in Quebec this
week,
isn't Quebec debating?
I use Neisha bill.
Uh,
yes,
it is.
Well,
so,
you know,
obviously even something as obvious as
thou shalt not kill can be nibbled to
death around the,
around the margins.
It's not obvious.
And these,
these belief systems,
the Judeo Christian belief system,
for example,
and this again is something that needs
to point it out,
is it's whole cloth.
You can't unravel part of it without the
rest of it unraveling.
So one of the precept positions is that
there's a judge.
That's God.
Something's watching you and your
ultimate response,
ultimately responsible for your moral
actions.
That's a big precept position,
you know,
and that's gone.
Yes,
it's gone for a significant minority.
Uh,
most,
uh,
most of the a 7 billion people,
like,
uh,
do partake of some kind of a faith.
Right.
But still have the notion of the future
though too.
Whoa.
There,
you know,
like there's plenty of idea of future in
the developing the few times to catch up
to the west.
Well,
yes,
but,
but they're there the in some ways,
but what we are,
what we are discovering is that the real
driver,
uh,
of,
believe in future is not as not a desire
for heightened morality,
uh,
or,
or universal morality.
But,
uh,
but the poverty and the poverty is what
makes people want to improve their lot.
Great.
Well,
there's no doubt that the western
countries in some sense,
solve the problem of poverty and we
still have the problem of relative
poverty.
I mean,
but the,
the,
the material wealth that we have seems
to be preferable to absolute poverty.
And so that means that the,
the drive for progress that,
that drove the West is still alive and
well in the developing countries.
It's thriving too,
because those countries are in fact
lifting themselves out of poverty.
Now,
whether or not to us,
but they already know that,
that uh,
that if they will proceed along the path
that we've already walked,
uh,
in the last a hundred,
hundred 50 years,
uh,
they will catch up with us and with our
kinds of problems and with our kinds of
questions about where to go next.
And so,
and so here he will return to the
question about,
about the future.
Do we,
do we need I an idea about how the story
ends for be able to,
to live it properly?
Well,
I was in New York on Friday with a group
called future earths and that's,
they're a group that was composed of,
let me just see here,
two major international science
consortium's natural science and social
science.
And that's exactly the sort of argument
or other sort of the questions they're
trying to address.
And the UN just produced a report on
sustainable development,
which is a document that is trying to
address that question as well.
What are we looking at?
Those documents tend to stress limits to
growth,
at least to some degree.
You know,
they're,
they're based on the presupposition that
we're running up against planetary
boundaries in our search for increasing
absolute wealth.
And that we have to figure out a way of
structuring our future so that it can be
sustainable across some longterm.
So the idea of sustainability,
whatever that means is trying to,
is,
is being posed as the alternative tube,
continual positive growth.
And there's,
there's variants of that like
sustainable development,
which means continual improvement within
the boundaries.
So one of the things that's changed
that,
okay,
we're starting to understand that,
that yeah,
we now have the technological capability
to exceed the planet's carrying power
carrying capacity.
And we have to do something about that.
No one's really sure how to translate
that recognition of limitation into an
ethic for action.
And most of the translation you see is,
um,
be more environmentally sensitive,
something like that.
You know,
keep the environment in mind when you're
making your local decisions.
But that's an ethic of limitation.
It doesn't seem to be very compelling.
It isn't exactly clear what that means
as you play your future out over the
shorter,
medium term.
So it's interesting that you,
uh,
this because in some ways
environmentalist was long than most,
uh,
crucial,
developments,
uh,
and the history of ideas and,
and it was born out of recognition that,
uh,
to pursue growth,
without any annual limitations,
uh,
it can be distracted,
um,
to,
uh,
to our sense of wellbeing.
At the same time.
One could suggest that ever mentalism
was,
uh,
um,
instrumental in,
in,
uh,
killing off the idea of progress.
Uh,
even though,
uh,
most people who I run into this with
gladly defined themselves as
progressive.
Uh,
do you agree that that kind of a
mechanism,
it was,
uh,
I was,
was,
uh,
responsible for demise of a progressive
attitude to us history?
Yeah,
I think,
I think it,
it,
it's a very complicated question.
I mean,
I would say from a mythological
perspective,
we'd gone from worshiping the great
father to starting to worship the great
mother.
I think the great mother being something
like die out,
you know,
uh,
the hypothetical planetary,
the integrated planetary system that has
been positive as functional by a number
of biologists.
I mean,
Gaya was actually named after,
I think a Greek goddess.
Um,
when we were worshiping the great father
that's more like the classical
patriarchy that the feminists talk
about.
And you know,
they would say that the patriarchy was
concerned with things like domination
and,
and a mastery mastery.
Yeah,
exactly.
And that's where the,
the eye,
the sub idea there is something like
nature is the chaotic enemy and it's,
it has to be overcome and mastered.
And you know,
when you reverse that you get no,
it's the patriarchal military industrial
complex.
That's the villain.
Then Mother Nature is the soft nurturing
force that stands underneath us that
demands respect and thing is,
is both those stories are true.
And even though they lead to opposite
conclusions,
they're both true strangely enough.
Because you know,
opposite things aren't supposed to be
true simultaneously,
but life is paradoxical.
So they often are.
So the question is,
well,
what happens when you start to worship
the great mother?
You get more concerned with
egalitarianism and distribution of
wealth.
I suppose that's part of it.
And you can think of that as as a
potential ethos for the future.
I mean we are making progress in that
direction because there are far fewer
people in poverty as a percentage of the
number of people that were alive then
there were 20 years ago and it looks
like that's going to continue.
You know,
it needs the,
these documents that are emanating from
the UN that talk about the future
certainly have poverty reduction as a
very high on their list of priorities as
well as whatever environmental concerns
are also outlined in the documents.
So the vision seems to be something
like,
well more attention to the conditions
under which flourishing as possible.
So don't destroy the ecosystems that
support us but also maintain the
possibility of lifting the rest of
humanity out of squalor.
Those two things might be mutually
necessary because you know,
it's people at the bottom of the
socioeconomic hierarchy that are forced
to do things like slash and burn
agriculture and,
and the burning of wood for heat and
cooking.
And you know,
those are heavily greenhouse gas
emitting processes.
So,
I mean I've,
I've come to believe that the,
the answer to the problem of the future
is actually something that manifests
itself more at a personal level.
Um,
you know,
you might say,
well,
what should you do in order to,
to make the future better?
And I think those answers kind of
beckoned in front of you.
What I've,
what I've tried to teach my students is
to try to make the quality of their
immediate experience better.
And because I think that that is
something that has cascading properties.
I mean,
in our first conversation we talked
about,
you know,
making one room in your house beautiful.
Well it's,
it's hard to make something beautiful
and if you do it even locally,
you learn something from that.
And if you could make something local,
beautiful and perfect,
then it gives you some ideas about how
to do it on a slightly larger scale.
And maybe it also gives you some
motivation to do that.
And then if you can do it on a slightly
larger scale,
well then you have some idea about how
you might even do it at a slightly
larger scale.
The guys we were down,
I went down to to New York on Friday to
talk about ideas of sustainable
development.
And one of the things that was really
stressed,
the group had brought a bunch of people
into act as critics of their ideas.
And one of the things that was discussed
continuously by the critics was the
importance of producing micro projects
that are designed to make things better
and scale them up rather than trying to
come up with a utopian vision from the
top and force it down.
And there's something about that that
seems right to me.
And,
and I think it's something that people
can engage in as individuals.
Start a micro project to make things
better around you.
And you might say,
well,
at what scale and answer to that is
whatever scale you can actually manage.
You know,
for some of my students that meant if
they were in fractured families for
example,
which was frequently the case or a
number one student who took on the
project of buying groceries for the
family and trying to organize their meal
times,
which turned out to be a way more
difficult thing than he had envisioned.
He wrote about it as he,
as he took on the responsibility,
but I think our best bet off,
I really do believe our best bet and and
the way forward in the future is to look
around in front of you in your immediate
environment and to try to make it
balanced and healthy.
And I think the cumulative consequences
of that will be that everything is
balanced and healthy.
One of the things we talked about at the
meeting was you know the intuition of
beauty because they don't think the,
the,
the apprehension of beauty is not
something rational.
It's,
it's outside rationality.
But the apprehension of beauty is
something that that help can help guide
us to construct environments that are
maximally beneficial I think.
I think that's what the sense of beauty
is.
Therefore,
also about the recognition of the beauty
of being present here and now.
Um,
because,
uh,
in some ways a,
this avoids the dilemma of,
of,
uh,
imagining that,
that we need to entrust ourselves to a
idealized future.
Yeah.
Well I think,
I think if something's beautiful,
I think partly what that means is that
the ideal future is embedded in it
already.
And that's why it's beautiful.
I mean,
the future is a tricky thing.
And,
and so are the things around us.
I mean,
everything around us contains what it is
in the present,
but it also contains the possibility of
the multiple things it could be in the
future.
And I think that when you apprehend
something that's beautiful or when you
construct something that's beautiful,
you're also constructing something that
has the kind of future you would most
want to like in it.
I mean,
I can give you,
I can give you a brief example of that.
I mean,
the Europe,
the Europeans spent centuries trying to
make their,
their cities and the buildings in the
beautiful far more than we've,
they've paid,
paid far more attention to that than we
do in the West or in North America
anyways.
And the consequence of that is that
everyone flocks to Europe to see the old
cities.
There's something about those old cities
that's right there.
Beautiful.
And yet you have to be right.
And being from,
from Europe,
I,
uh,
I obviously grew up in,
in,
uh,
in May,
in a number of cities in Europe and,
uh,
and every time I go back to you,
I must say that I'm troubled by the fact
that many of the cities are precisely
that they are beautiful and nothing
else.
It should be done to them,
uh,
to enhance the beauty.
They as beautiful as they as they can be
in with talking about Paris,
superrich Rome,
uh,
garth in Burke,
Stockholm,
uh,
pick any of those cities.
And then you'd be hard pressed to
imagine what else needs to be done to
make them better.
Right?
But that is in itself a problem,
a problem precisely caused by the
question that we are discussing here
today,
which is there,
there the city is no longer have a need
for future and,
and,
and if you don't have that need,
then you are stuck.
You are stuck and,
and you are frozen.
And we don't know.
I don't think we know what to do with
that.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
I guess I understand what you're saying.
some of those cities have become sort of
living museums because of that.
Although I guess maybe in some ways
that's not such a bad destani given the
number of people around the world who
are going to want to travel.
But there's certainly no shortage of
beautification that could be done in the
world's remaining cities.
And I think that also speaks to
environmental concerns.
I mean,
I read some books a while ago about
Chesapeake Bay before the Europeans came
and Chesapeake Bay was one of the
richest natural environments,
I think that ever existed on the planet.
And what's striking about the writings
about the original Chesapeake Bay is the
description of their natural beauty.
And you know,
it's enough to make you weep.
It's,
it's enough to make you weak to realize
how productive than and remarkable those
ecosystems once were.
And I mean,
to me,
the fact that those,
those places are gone increasingly gone
is reflected most particularly in a
decrease in the beauty of the world.
And that's I think a direction for the
future.
What kind of world do we want?
Well,
it would be lovely to have a world that
you know,
is unimaginably beautiful and that's
something that people could work towards
and you can do that locally and it,
but in some way sustainability has
become persaya precisely the response to
the idea of progress that,
that there's no longer a question of,
of how to eh change and,
and create a database says never just
before,
but precisely to be able to,
um,
uh,
retained and protect the threat.
Great.
I think that the idea of sustainability,
I think it's gone.
This is something that came up in the
discussions in New York too,
is that sustainability is,
it's kind of a vow shall not ethic.
It's,
you know,
human beings have raped and pillaged
long enough and it's time for us to
start limiting our appetites so that you
know,
other things beside us,
which also have rights can flourish.
It's like,
no,
that isn't,
that isn't what I mean,
that isn't what I'm talking about.
And the reason I,
the reason for that is I think that's,
I think that that's built on a
fundamentally antihistamine.
MMM,
okay.
Okay.
An anti human mythology.
I mean,
it's sort of like the state of being
before Noah's flood.
You know,
human beings are evil and sinful and
we're running around making too much
noise and the best thing to happen would
be that nature could come back and wash
us all the way with the flood.
So we should be careful and scaled back
and be good.
I don't think,
like people aren't built to live inside
limits like that.
W that isn't because our central
mythologies are hero mythologies.
There are about going out and
transforming chaos into order.
They're not about,
you know,
being guilty about who we are and having
to live inside a fence for the safety of
everything else.
And,
and yet any of match a match how the
ethos is precisely about that.
Well that's why you don't trust it.
I think,
you know,
as a psychoanalyst,
whenever anybody ever pause,
it's a good,
I always wonder,
you know,
what the downside to what their positing
is and what the negative motivations
might be.
And I've met plenty.
I've met plenty of environment metalists
and heard from many more who clearly
don't like people.
I heard a professor at Queen's
university when I was there doing a Tedx
talk.
It was one of the most appalling things
I've ever heard in my life is this guy
came out.
Um,
and he used the Tedx talk as a forum to
harangue all the 18 and 19 year olds in
the audience about,
you know,
the essential evilness of humanity.
His decision to,
to,
I think you only had one child on his
decision to limit as repor duction and
his strong emphasis on the immorality of
them doing anything but that.
So he's out there talking to all 18 and
19 year old kids.
In his basic attitude was,
you know,
human beings are so awful that the only
moral thing you can do as young people
is to make bloody sure you don't
replicate too many of yourselves.
It's like,
sorry,
I didn't trust that guy.
I think,
I think I thought he was profoundly and
dangerously anti human and a lot of the
rhetoric that drives the
environmentalist movement is resentful,
anti humanism and it's,
that's no,
that's not the kind of thing that can
guide the development of a positive
future if that,
you know,
I've heard environment,
let's say things like the planet would
be better off if people,
if there were no people on it or human
beings are like a cancer.
It's like,
sorry buddy,
I'm not taking any guidelines from you.
That to me that sort of ethos is one
step away from genocidal thinking.
I really mean that too.
No,
it's,
it's hatred for humanity under the guise
of love of mother nature.
You know,
I think the same thing about a lot of
the animal rights guys who want to,
you know,
give rats the same rights as people is
they want nothing to have rights.
They don't rat want wraps to have the
rights of people there.
It's very dangerous and,
and yet,
and yet and yet for all fall on the
critical,
uh,
notions that you bring to the a and the
mentalist cause and those who,
uh,
who exhibited in the bureau and fashion
yourself have a later became quite
concerned with aspects of incremental,
a distraction.
And you've given a talk about it,
about the need to rescue our oceans.
Yeah.
Well that's pretty soon that talk will
be online pretty soon.
Well,
I got invited to,
to help work on a UN document a few
years ago,
which was the Secretary Generals High
Level Panel on global sustainability.
I think that was the name of it.
It's got an awkward title so it escapes
my mind.
But I was invited by the Canadian who
sat on the committee because he believed
that the,
um,
underlying narrative of the UN document
was outdated and inappropriate.
And it was outdated because it was still
kind of a cold war document.
There was still a lot of north versus
south in at and a lot of,
uh,
you know,
capitalism versus socialism slash
communism and you know,
it was 40 years out of date.
Plus it was far too pessimistic about
the progress that human beings have made
in the last 30 years.
You know,
it didn't take into account the fact
that there aren't very many dictators
anymore and that way fewer people are in
poverty and that we've made a lot of
progress in getting rid of terrible
communicable diseases and that,
you know,
there are 7 billion of us and hardly
anybody starving and our population has
done to level off at 9,000,000,008
and then start to decline.
So we're in a bottleneck,
but we might be able to get through it
anyways.
While I was working on that document and
trying to clean up the underlying
narratives,
um,
to make it more balanced.
And I wouldn't say more optimistic,
but less anti-human,
I would say.
I did a lot of reading about the
ecological condition,
so to speak.
And you know about global warming and
that kind of thing and pretty much
everything I could get my hands on.
And I read a lot of books on the state
of the ocean and they were really
depressing.
I mean,
we are really,
really destroying the oceans and that's,
that's not good.
And it's not because I'm an
environmentalist that I say that's not
good.
It's because anybody with any sense can
see that the loss of the beauty and
dynamism of the oceans would make the
world a less good place to live in for
people.
You know,
not just for the creatures that are in
the sea,
but you really want to live in a ocean
that's full of nothing but jellyfish.
I mean,
first of all,
Jelly fish don't like human beings very
much.
If there's too many,
too many of them around,
you're not going to be doing a lot of
swimming in the ocean.
For example,
I was reading this week,
okay,
most people don't know this,
but you know,
the ocean seems really big,
but almost all the Fisher on the
continental shelf and the continental
shelf forney extends a couple of hundred
miles off the continent,
which is why it's called the continental
shelf.
And so it isn't that big an area and
that's where all the fish are.
Well,
right now we trawl the continental shelf
twice a year,
completely,
completely.
That's like mowing the continent with a
lawnmower twice a year.
And you know,
it's just,
it's mind boggling.
And trawlers they're there,
they're quite the things,
you know,
they basically,
you with a trawler,
you take a big way to net,
like a huge way to knit and you drag it
across the ocean floor and you disturb
the entire surface of the floor and you
raise a huge clouds of dust that,
that pollute the water for,
for even hundreds of miles around.
And you take absolutely everything and
then you haul it up to the surface and
then you take one 10th of it,
which is the stuff that you're allowed
to harvest and that's commercially
viable.
The other 90% is dead and you throw all
of that back.
So I mean,
that's only one of 50 stories about
ocean degradation that you know,
easily come to mind.
So I think that's terrifying.
And I also think that our obsessive
concern with global warming is blinding
us to,
um,
ecological catastrophes that are much
more at hand and that would actually be
more solvable.
At least something could be done about
them.
So,
so we are almost 10 yet again,
to summarize,
it's a bit,
um,
uh,
so,
so we obviously the profound needs that
we recognize I have to do with the
damage that,
that,
uh,
a thoughtless,
advancement of technology and
satisfaction of human needs as broad.
Um,
that's,
that's a,
obviously you feel powerfully about
that,
uh,
as a,
as regards to the oceans,
uh,
I feel powerful you about it when it's
done stupidly.
I mean there's,
you know,
if you have a crop,
if you have a herd of cows,
you don't shoot every one of them.
You know,
that's,
that's not good for you.
It's not good for the cows,
obviously,
but it's really not good for you.
So it isn't,
it isn't,
it isn't even the sacrifice of natural
resources to the advancement of human
beings.
That concerns me.
It's the fact that a lot of it's being
done in a way that is clearly have no
benefit to anyone.
Yeah.
Wasteful.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the,
the question,
the question that,
that we're trying to address here is,
uh,
is,
um,
how to think about the future and,
and,
uh,
whether or not we can draw some solace
from,
uh,
some notions about what the future can
be to,
to,
to deal with,
with the,
the question of,
uh,
of social meaning,
because history was very much about,
about offering us as a,
as a,
as a mankind,
mankind,
as a,
as a collectivity Sam frame within which
to think about the past,
present,
and then tomorrow.
And the question is whether or not that
frame,
uh,
it's available to us without that
timeframe is available to us that allows
us to bookend our existence.
Yeah.
Well I said,
you know,
after,
after many years of thinking about this,
the,
I,
I've got kind of radically local in my,
in my thinking I,
because I became so disenchanted with
large scale political solutions to
things because of the dangers associated
with that.
I mean I think the way forward is for
people to concentrate more intently on,
on their individual lives and the
quality and integrity of those lives and
to learn what they can from Pur pursuing
high quality,
high integrity lies and then just start
applying that at broader scales.
It's a bottom up idea,
you know,
and it,
it,
I think it's,
I think it's the properly he humble sort
of idea.
You know,
it's getting your own house in order and
then worry about what,
I wouldn't say even the rest of the
world at that point,
get your own house in order and then
worry about your local community if you
can manage that than worry about what's
beyond your local community.
And I,
I think there is rich meaning and not,
my experience has been that there's rich
meaning and not because there's
something about setting your own house
in order that's really compelling.
It's an adventure,
it's a compelling adventure.
It's also very difficult and you learn
things from doing it,
you know?
And as I said,
I've run lots of students through this
process and they've essentially come to
the same conclusion.
So I would say the,
the future isn't out in distant time
anymore.
Like it was.
I think the future is right in front of
us now and I mean literally right in
front of us.
And if we improve what's right in front
of us,
then that improvement will propagate out
okay.
Temporally and spatially.
And I don't see what are other option is
because what are you going to do?
You're going to try to direct things 10,
10,
20 years into the future.
God,
I can't even imagine what's going to be
like them.
Well,
I,
I think,
I think a key phrase for this
conversation in the future is here,
and then that's the only way in which we
can take care of it.
Um,
thank you,
Jordan,
uh,
to be continued,
in,
in the future.
Either still this motto when we get back
to work after some break.
Uh,
anyway.
but thank you and,
uh,
are the best.
Bye.